ce qui était normalement le thème de ce
soir ces images que l'on a vu hier
notamment square bellarmin à paris ou
bien ici à côté du canal saint-martin
ambiance
[Musique]
la donc canal saint martin hier et dans
bien d'autres lieux à paris bien
d'autres lieux en france dans notamment
plusieurs grandes villes bordeaux lyon
marseille
alors on a posé la question beaucoup il
ya beaucoup de réactions sur les
commentaires du dans les commentaires du
figaro on va y revenir
déjà beaucoup de réactions qui tombe
depuis tout à l'heure mais j'ai demandé
puisqu'on l'avait tout à l'heure en
interviews en plateau au professeur
christian perronne auteur d'un livre
choc contre la gestion de la crise du
coronavirus ce qu'ils pensaient de ces
rassemblements
il faut que les français restent
prudents et ne passent que les regarder
ce qui ce qui s'est passé en allemagne
les allemands n'ont pas confiné de façon
autoritaire ils ont dit aux allemandes
et responsables de savoir gérer deux
d'être de s'isoler quand il était malade
de faire attention dans leurs contacts
sociaux et les allemands géré par auto
discipline et là je pense que là les
français de maths temps en temps être
plus disciplinés voilà et cette
interview du professeur peron est à
retrouver dans son intégralité sur le
portail figaro live dans la rubrique les
derniers direct rubrique qui existe à la
faveur de la rénovation de ce portail
que je vous invite à les regarder dans
vos commentaires
il y a notamment ce commentaire celui de
gars base qui a l'impression de vivre
dans un pays sans gouvernance chacun
fait ce qu'il veut
les règles n'existent plus céline pina
si votre micro fonctionne du nouveau
quel est votre avis est ce que vous
partagez la vie justement de cet
internaute en fait pas exactement donc
est ce que le micro fonctionne là ça va
ou même extrêmement bien mieux ce serait
indécent alors en fait ce que je crois
surtout c'est qu'on a oublié d'abord on
n'a pas la même histoire que l'allemagne
mais surtout on a oublié que aujourd'hui
la priorité c'est de remettre les gens
au travail c'est très clair donc on
avait installé un certain nombre de
rendez-vous qui angoisse est un petit
peu les gens mais qui les remettaient
dans le fait qu'on était dans une
urgence sanitaire
c'était le fait que très régulièrement
nous donner le nombre de morts c'est un
peu morbide on peut peut-être faire un
peu moins souvent et tout d'un coup on a
lâché
dire tous ces rituels pour repartir dans
aller travailler et c'est nécessaire la
seule chose c'est qu'on a peut-être on
est peut-être passé du protégez vous
allez travailler en ne gérant pas très
très bien les intermédiation et là on
voit qu'il ya une angoisse qui revient
parce que dans un certain nombre de pays
on voit arriver une deuxième vague quand
on regarde les images de la fête de la
musique on se dit ben normalement ici
qu'un jouant les avoir quelques
problèmes dans les hôpitaux parisiens
mais comment voulez-vous à la fois des
rouges en aller travailler expliqué
qu'on va baisser finalement assouplir
les règles sanitaires au sein des
collèges ou de toute façon on peut même
plus les tenir aujourd'hui donc on fait
semblant est tombé sur des gens qui tout
d'un coup se disent bon bah voilà ça y
est c'est terminé et qu'ils ont une
folle envie de se retrouver on est
humain on a envie de se toucher on a
envie de s'approcher et dès qu'on est
trop nombreux j'ai vu des gens qu'ils
m'expliquent qu'ils avaient fait un
enterrement ils me disent vous avez au
bout d'un moment on se connaît tous on
est vain et bien la france finit par
pleurer dans les bras les uns des autres
et on sait que ces coins mais mais c'est
comme ça ça fait partie de l'humanité
donc je pense que c'est dangereux j'ai
beaucoup de mal à être violente avec les
les personnes je crois que si le
gouvernement était plus claire et plus
carré on n'en serait peut-être pas non
plus là les chars bouygues
vous avez été fêté l'été dans la rue
hier soir également
donc je suis passé voir des
rassemblements qui se déroulait dans mon
arrondissement et qui se déroulait avec
plutôt une ambiance décontractée et
beaucoup moins de monde que les images
que vous avez montré qu'ils ont existé
par ailleurs dans paris mais tout paris
les inventaires non mais justement elle
tout n'était pas à l'image de 6 vous
avez montré c'est ce que je voulais
indiquez moi dans ce qu'est beaucaire et
céline pinard je reviens sur la partie
très confuse des règles qui sont
aujourd'hui donner à la population
en fait c'est comme si d'un côté on
avait une population avec déjà le
confinement dans sa tête et des règles
qui étaient très dures
appréhendé qu'elle soit celle de l'école
parce qu'elle change qu'elle soit celle
des commerces parce qu'elles ont aussi
évolué et se contient des marchés est ce
qu on ne vient pas des marchés on
maintient des gestes barrières avec des
protocoles qui sont parfois pas très
clair à comprendre même pour des
professionnels le temps de distancer un
mail de distance latérale alors là
celle-là faudra vraiment on nous
explique d'où elle vient
elle est sûrement très pertinente mais à
mettre en oeuvre c'est quand même
quelque chose des défunts d'édifiant
c'est à dire que vous pouvez les deux
ados ça n'a pas de problème par contre
en latéral vous devez avoir toujours un
mètre de distance il ya l'impression de
règles est très confuse avec le
sentiment pour certaines professions
qu'il ya une forme d'injustice que
certains peuvent faire des choses que
d'autres ne le peuvent pas que tout ça
reste très flou et hier effectivement
c'est une fête de la musique on ne peut
pas dire que les images que l'on a vues
puisse nous surprendre tous les ans la
fête de la musique est l'occasion de
rassemblements et il n'y a pas eu
d'interdiction et donc sans interdiction
il ya eu aussi envie de se retrouver à
un moment donné les jeunes expliqué
c'était pas forcément pour braver des
règles pour se retrouver pour être
ensemble ont partagé un moment
moi j'ai pas envie non plus de jeter de
jeter la pierre c'est d'ailleurs elle
sait qu'à paris le prat a lyon la tuque
des rassemblements je dis ça parce que
le petit anti parisianisme propos qui
pourraient arriver serait pas forcément
non plus de meilleur augure des règles
plus claires ni choses plus claires
encore je crois le le permettrait
davantage
alors si l'anti parisianisme bobo est
une tentation effectivement lancinante
en tous les cas on n'y a pas céder sur
ce point là puisque avant de vous poser
la question j'avais bien pris soin de
préciser que c'était le cas à paris mais
dans plusieurs grandes villes notamment
à lyon marseille ou bordeaux
georges kuzmanovic pour alimenter le
débat
je voudrais vous partagez un tweet c'est
celui de notre confrère jean pierre
denis qui est le futur ex directeur de
la rédaction de la vie parce qu'il prend
du galon part
dans un autre groupe celui de bayard et
qui a eu ce tweet ironique là pour dire
que c'est la faute aux évangéliques
ce sera plus compliqué mais bon on
devrait pouvoir y arriver
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais jamais
en ligue b évangélique jeudi
sous-entendu qu'il ya deux dans le fils
de jean pierre denis en gros jean pierre
denis depuis longtemps que les
évangéliques qui le rassemblement de
mulhouse a servi de boucs émissaires
dans cette affaire
et quand on voit
les quand on voit le rassemblement qu'il
y a eu hier à paris ces rassemblements
formelle qui a eu un fort mal qui ont eu
lieu hier à paris et dans plusieurs
grandes villes
il dit que là ce sera difficile
d'imputer la course au rassemblement
évangélique de mulhouse voilà il compare
des carottes et des pommes de terre ce
qu'on fait pas un mathématiques
les évangéliques sont des organisations
religieuses qui se sont organisés qui se
réunissent à dessein en demandant des
gens ne se retrouvent et puis on sait
qu'à mulhouse comme en corée du sud ils
ont été fortement la source de la
pandémie
là ce sont plutôt des gens qui se
réunissent de manière spontanée et je
suis assez d'accord avec avec les autres
intervenants on vit pas avec un fichier
excel dans la tête
or des époques de pandémie les fêtes de
bayonne en imoca j'ai participé jeunes
et moins jeunes en fin de soirée ne
m'ont pas laissé une impression de
folles contrôle de soi de la jeunesse
des gens apprennent peuvent prendre les
voitures étant ce qui est pas bien mais
voilà c'est la jeunesse se fait comme ça
l'histoire l'histoire des pandémies
montre que après une période de
sidération après la vie reprend même
avec je pense aux écrits de l'époque de
la peste antonina rome où finalement la
vie reprend ou lors de la peste noire il
ya tous ces célèbres s'est même donné un
genre c'était et danses macabres et les
et et tableaux qui allait avec
donc bon peut-être que c'est une sorte
forme de danse macabre qui correspond à
une période un peu hédoniste dans
laquelle nous sommes
voilà il faut aussi les jeunes qui
veulent sortir un peu ras-le-bol après
trois mois de de confinement ccc ccc
anthropologique mais c'est comme ça et
puis effectivement c'est pal je vais pas
répéter ce que les autres mais c'est
quand même il n'y a pas une grande
cohérence au niveau du gouvernement leur
faudra pas demander un jeune de 22 ans
qui va peut sortir d'en avoir plus que
ceux qui nous gouvernent
dieu yoann nous dit jacques de saint
victor je vous donne la parole je donne
la parole juste avant à nos internautes
armelle nous dit le protocole sanitaire
allégé à partir d'aujourd'hui il aurait
pu le faire hier pour la fête de la
musique mazu lui est aussi où elle était
aussi choqués que l plutôt que par les
manifestations autorisées seach nom
ainsi que j'étais sur le rn qui nous
parlait donc on en a parlé tout à
l'heure babineau qui nous dit vous nous
dites je déplore l'absence de masques
mais en même temps le gouvernement à
tolérer une manifestation de plus de
vingt mille personnes
nathan est plus ironique il nous dit en
termes économiques
on peut conclure qu on a échangé 1 ou 2%
du pib contre la fête de la musique
géniale non sachant qu'il y a bientôt le
deuxième tour des élections dit lidia
donc s'il ya des cas ce sera lors de la
fête de la musique
je rappelle qu'on vous pose la question
etes-vous choqué par les images des
rassemblements sans les gestes barrière
lors de la fête de la musique dans
plusieurs grandes villes de france
eh bien vous êtes à rebours de ce que
disent nos intervenants puisque vous
êtes 70% à nous répondre oui
franck nous dit notamment sur twitter
ce qui me choque c'est que l'on emmerdes
ceux qui bossent avec des normes en veux
tu en voilà
et on laisse faire des cancres ou bien
olivier qui nous dit après on se permet
de critiquer la gestion de la crise on a
tout oublié les morts les conséquences
du confinement enfants masqués à l'école
on a surtout oublié que le virus peut
être fatale mais ne pas fêter ou
manifester ne le sont pas et enfin une
catalane aib qui nous écrit du canada
nous dit il ya quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas en france pourquoi les
manifestations ne vous gênez pas et
l'aso
les regroupements soit on ne vous
dérange pas donc c'est il pointe
justement la cohérence votre point de
vue jacques je signale celui de yoann
encore qui nous dit encore et il ya une
deuxième vague due à des jeunes qui font
la fête la fête de la musique aurait dû
être interdite d'êta fait n'importe quoi
c'est ce que j'aurais j'aurais voulu
dire donc je veux pas épiloguer c'est
pas très très original mais paraît en
effet très étonnant que on autorise
cette fête de la musique qui est dans un
contexte comme celui que l'on vient de
vivre alors je sais bien comme l'a dit
jack osmanovic qu'on en oublie vite
mais justement c'est la responsabilité
tout de même des pouvoirs publics après
nous avoir fait subir du fait de leur
impéritie parce que l'absence de masques
c'est tout de même une ou des
responsabilités majeures des autorités
nous avoir fait subir deux mois de
confinement
eh bien on laisse faire tout de suite
après une fête de la musique avec ses
scènes
on vient de voir qu'ils sont évidemment
logique du point de vue en effet des
jeunes car on peut pas faire une fête
sans faire la fête le fameux homo
festivus de bure et trouve la réaliser
dans toute sa splendeur mais on a des
autorités qui normalement sont là pour
justement veiller à ce que ça ne se
fasse pas je ne crois pas que les
discothèques soient réouvertes je crois
même que même tout cet été elles ne
seront pas ouvertes donc ça paraît très
étonnant et bon évidemment un murray
s'imposait mais j'aurais voulu citer un
livre du sociologue qui est peut-être
vrai mollahs à l'ordre du jour avec ce
qui vient de se passer c'est un saut sur
le peu connu qui s'appelle le ix postman
et qui a écrit un livre qui s'appelle se
divertir à en mourir et là on est
vraiment quasiment dans ce dans ce cas
de figure c'est à dire que évidemment
les jeunes eux ne vont pas avoir les
conséquences dramatiques que l'on que
l'on sait puisque généralement le virus
ne touche pas la population jeune mais
on oublie au nom de cette hyper
individualisme que soulignent des
intervenants
on oublie que il risque en revanche de
contaminer d'autres personnes à cons
à commencer par l'or
roux leurs grands parents donc voilà je
trouve que c'est une responsabilité
forte du gouvernement
désolé de d'avoir ce discours un peu
moins consensuel vis-à-vis de cette fête
de la musique il aurait fallu interdire
vous casser un peu l'ambiance mon cher
jacques mais yoann est d'accord avec
vous demain les mêmes qui s'amusent
pleureront le manque d'emplois due à la
crise économique
êtes vous choqué par les images des
rassemblements sans les gestes barrière
lors de la fête de musique dans
plusieurs grandes villes de france et
vous répondu oui à 76% donc c'est un
petit peu moins que
au début de l'émission est donc à croire
que certains ont été convaincus par une
partie des arguments et qu'ils ont est
donné